veillée d'armes pour l'ol battre tout à
l'heure le paris saint germain tout en
souhaitant voir nîmes triomphé de
l'ogcnice c'est le dernier pari de la
saison pour l'olympique lyonnais à
l'issue de cette mossad année de
championnat hors de ces deux hypothèses
point de salut et lyon sera sinon et
s'est du reste prévisible
contraint de jouer les barrages entre le
vainqueur lui aussi désigné ce soir du
match
avignon rennes ce dernier pari ce sera
aussi celui de l'entraîneur de
l'olympique lyonnais
aimé jacquet qui on le sait tout gerland
pour bordeaux la logique
2 du métier qui veut parfois il faut
s'en aller je regrette un petit peu
l'ambiance nyonnaise mes enfants
j'espère pour redémarrer dans un autre
club en première division il refaire ce
que
j'essaie à lyon c'est à dire animer un
club avec beaucoup d'enthousiasmé donner
une bonne ambiance
on se souvient en effet qu'aimé jacquet
est arrivé à l'ol il y à 7 ans avec un
contrat pro en main après une carrière
stéphanoise il évolua du reste que fort
peu dans les rangs lyonnais n'ayant joué
que deux ou trois matches au poste de
libéro il prit ensuite les rênes de la
troisième division capon et mignot
limogé c'est en février 76 qu'aimé
jacquet devint entraîneur de l'équipe
une
il sauva alors de la relégation le
palmarès de ce père de famille frisant
la quarantaine une place de 6e en 77 une
rechute à la 17e place en 78 une remonté
à la 7e place en 79 et une saison 80 qui
se joue maintenant en fond de tableau on
le voit des dents de scie pour un club
lyonnais qui se cherche qui raillait par
ses effectifs aux jeunes la malchance
télé problèmes financiers en ce qui
concerne la saison nous avons une une
période des périodes très difficiles du
bon à notre inexpérience et à notre
jeunesse mais aussi à de nombreux
blessés
ce qui fait que cette équipe a toujours
été un déséquilibre et a toujours douté
un peu d'elle-même mais ma grande
satisfaction c'est que notre fin de
saison a démontré une certaine qualité
une certaine valeur et je crois qu'à
l'image de ce soir lyon vaulx beaucoup d
équipes françaises et je suis persuadé
que dans l'est dans les années à venir
elle va prendre de l'expérience et
donner le meilleur d'elle-même
dans l'ensemble il ya une une
progression qui n'a pas été constante
pour la simple et unique raison c'est
que le doute s'était installé dans cette
équipe du du fait que nous venions pas
souvent alors si vous voulez pour des
joueurs qui sont très jeunes et qui
n'ont pas encore l'expérience
deux des anciens ils n'ont pas donné
leur meilleur rendement et je crois que
avec les victoires
justement le rendement sera meilleur
jacques et s'en va destrumelle arrive
avec peut-être dans ses valises ses
fameuses victoire dont a tant besoin le
club lyonnais
[Musique]